FEMALE SPEAKER: Welcome to
Photographers at Google, a new
series that we're putting
together.
And we're really excited
to have Alan
Shapiro with us today.
He's from New York, visiting
us here at Mountain View at
Google headquarters, so it's
great to have you, Alan.
He is the chief creative officer
at the world's largest
advertising network, and he's
worked on projects such as
M&M, Mars, Heineken, and Dos
Equis, and Unilever.
He's award-winning photographer,
he's passionate
about photography, and he's
been published in private
collections and galleries, and
he has a real talent for
getting people to
open up to him.
In fact, I got to witness
this just the
other day at Chinatown.
He can get people to smile with
joy or sorrow, and at one
point, he had an old woman with
a cane about to hit him
over the head, but she was
smiling, so it's all good.
And his words reflect and
archive the moment that he
captures behind the camera.
And so the topic today he
will be sharing is Dear
Photographers, Use Your Words.
And I'm pleased and excited to
have Alan Shapiro join us
today, so thank you.
ALAN SHAPIRO: That's it?
Come on.
AUDIENCE: Confetti will be--
ALAN SHAPIRO: Later.
Alright.
You see?
[APPLAUSE]
Wow, that's cool.
Crowd control.
I'm actually really humbled and
feel incredibly privileged
to be here, so thank you Laurie,
and Brian, and all of
you for coming.
Google has literally
changed my life.
Google+ has changed my life,
but Google as an entity has
changed my life.
And so for all of you, and all
of your peers, thank you.
Because as a society, what I
call this Generation ADD,
we're jumping around way too
much, and that can be an
opportunity, but it can
also be a detriment.
And the technology that you've
created has brought us all
closer, has given way to umpteen
amounts of information
that we can share, and I think
it's a wonderful thing.
But that's not what I'm
here to talk about.
So we're going up we're going
to erase this part.
I'm going to go back a little
bit, and I want to look at
that photo.
It was the first photo that,
as a young child--
by the way I've only been
photographing for about six,
seven years, but that photo
stuck with me throughout my
entire life.
And now, I want you to--
anyone know what the
background for that photo is?
Other than Karen.
Anyone know what was going on?
Isn't that a shame?
One of the most iconic,
brilliant people in the world
sticking his tongue out.
So if you're a photographer,
what happened?
How did you do that?
If you're Einstein, what
made you do that?
And so, there's not a lot on the
internet other than being
able to find out that one of
the photographers, Arthur
Sasse, who worked for UPI
at the time, and it was
Einstein's 72nd birthday, and
he's tired of having all the
photographers take his picture,
so he stuck his
tongue out and it made for one
of the most iconic portraits
in modern times.
But now that's good, but
it's not good enough.
What was it like for Arthur?
Anyone have any idea?
I'm a photographer, and I love
working with people, and if I
had the opportunity to get in
front of an Einstein, or Larry
Page, or Sergey, or whoever I
happen to find here, what
would I do?
What would I think?
How would I feel?
And so, I think there's a
huge lost opportunity.
So let me go to another one.
Anybody know anything
about this photo?
Another iconic photo in our
modern day history, Dorothea
Lange, photographing during
the Depression in the
vegetable fields here
in California.
What went on?
So, you can find a little
bit of information.
The thing that speaks to me--
and I want to read this to
you, because it's the genesis
of this talk--
I saw and approached the hungry,
desperate mother as if
drawn by a magnet.
And I want you thinking
about Dorothea now.
You probably know nothing
about her.
There aren't that many recorded
interviews with her,
but as you listen to the
words, think about the
photographer and how that makes
you feel about her, and
that becomes a branding
opportunity.
I don't remember how to explain
my presence or my
camera to her, but
I do remember
she asked me no questions.
I can't imagine that moment.
I made five exposures, working
closer and closer from the
same direction.
I didn't ask her name
or her history.
She told me her age, that she
was 32, that she had been
living on frozen vegetables from
the surrounding fields
and the birds that her
children killed.
That she had just sold
the tires from her
car to pay for food.
Then she sat in the lean-to tent
with her children, and
somehow thought that her
picture, Dorothea's picture,
might help.
How do you feel about the
photographer now?
Do you like Dorothea?
Do you like the mom?
Do you know enough?
So most people here, I hope,
are photographers.
Even if you think you're a
photographer, or don't think
you're a photographer, you've
got a device that will let you
take a picture.
So we're all photographers.
Welcome to the club.
Some of us are a little more
passionate, a little bit more
involved, make a little bit more
money, but we all have
this opportunity to document
society, and that's a
wonderful thing.
There has never been a better
time to put pictures up, to
share them, to see the world in
its infinitesimally small
bits, because of photographers
around the world.
Again, thank you, Google+ for
bringing that to my life.
But now, there's a
lot of laziness
that accompanies that.
You take a picture, you post it,
you take another picture,
and you post it.
If you're a family photographer,
you pick thirty
pictures and you post it,
and then that's it.
Now there are some people, I
don't mean to overgeneralize,
who do write, and I love you.
I love you.
And I love the people who will
provide the context, because
that's what this is about.
Now the reaction--
so here's the reaction
to use your words.
Some people will shout loudly.
Sorry I had to get this in,
Brian, you know that.
But most often, when I teach, I
get this look, or this look,
sometimes this look, and
usually this look.
The story that goes with this,
this is my 100-year-old
grandmother, who passed away
just a few months ago, after
turning 100.
A few years back, my two
children and I were visiting,
and I was taking thousands of
pictures, and she was getting
annoyed, because at the time,
she was 97 or 98, and the
camera clicking, you
get annoyed.
She said, please stop.
And I wouldn't, because
I couldn't.
She's my grandmother.
And the kids whispered in her
ear, give him the finger.
And she didn't know what that
meant, so she did this to me.
And then she did this,
and then, someone--
my daughter--
whispered in her other ear, no,
it's the middle finger.
And so she did it.
She did it, and there's
that photo.
And she said, but what
does it mean?
She had no idea what it meant.
And so my son whispered in her
ear, and she said, why would I
do that to my grandson?
I adore him.
And my daughter said, well,
people do it to him in New
York all the time.
So before you heard that story,
which is one of my
favorite stories about one of my
most favorite people, and I
have shared it, and it has
gone around the world.
And this is now in the
collection of a very large
insurance company.
It sits in one of their hidden
hallways that they only show
special people, because
it is what it is.
But now, does that make
a difference to you?
Does that help a little bit?
Do you feel a little bit
different about Bubby or Alan?
So what's the difference
that words make?
Now, I'm going to talk,
and this isn't
going to be a lecture.
I'm going to show you a lot of
pictures, and I'm going to
tell you a lot of stories, but I
want you to think about just
the four things.
One, we're able to document
everything now, thanks to
cameras, thanks to Google Maps,
thanks to all of the
technology that allows us to
capture all of these things,
and that's important.
But now we want to go
beyond metadata.
So what are the happenings that
are going on, and what
can we do to add a little bit
more context to that?
Now, I'm a portrait photographer
sometimes.
So sometimes it's about
making connections.
Because when I approach someone,
I'm not one of those
stealthy guys, I'm going
to come up here, see?
And I'm going to
make you smile.
And I'll bet I could
make you cry.
AUDIENCE: Probably.
ALAN SHAPIRO: And that's where
the connections, the using
your words as a photographer,
is equally important.
It's not just after the fact,
it's before the fact.
Education.
I think this is the single
most important thing that
photographers should do, and I
can tell you, having worked
with some very iconic
photographers, it's the last
thing they want to do, because
everyone has secrets.
I don't want to share
my secrets.
Sorry.
I don't want to share
my secrets.
And to those people, I would
say, you have to share your
secrets, because that's going
to make you a better
photographer.
Because as soon as people know
how you do what you do, it's
going to force you to
do something else.
So instead of getting stuck
in a rut, teach.
And by the way, I'm a huge fan
of causes, and I think teacher
should be paid like rock stars
and athletes, and athletes and
rock stars should be forced to
teach, but that's a whole
other talk.
So let's talk about, sort
of, beginnings.
I think every photographer,
whether you're a starving
college kid, or middle
aged guy who picks it
up to reduce stress--
and by the way, that's
exactly what I did.
I work in advertising, I've
spent lots of time with
photographers, I was sort of
jealous of them because they
seem to have a lot
of fun working
with models and whatever.
But I also got very stressed,
and a photographer friend of
mine put a camera in my hand,
and I immediately got too
happy place.
But as a storyteller in my day
job, as someone who create
stories around brands, the idea
of seeing what stories
emerge from my photographs, what
could I do with them that
either illustrate, enhance,
complement, provide context?
That became important to me.
And it became a daily
exercise regimen.
You really are passing that
around, aren't you?
Cool.
Good, OK.
Just worried about the guy
in the white hair.
Don't know that I trust him.
So like most New Yorkers,
there's a huge homeless
population.
Which, to me, is absolutely a
horrible thing, as I'm sure
this to a lot of people.
No one likes it.
And so we started
spending time.
But this was a bad photograph
for me, because I couldn't
talk to this person.
You know I later went back,
and I got to know Jason,
because homeless people
have a territory, and
I got to know him.
This is one of my favorite
stories, and this is something
that I may get mushy about.
This is a gentleman named Boris,
and he is easily the
scariest person I've ever met
when he is off his meds.
And he's rarely medicated, and
when he has medicine, people
steal it from the shelters.
He's horribly scary.
But as is my thing, I would
walk by, and I would leave
lunch bags, breakfast
food, whatever.
And they never talk to me, and
I really kept my distance.
But then one day, he said,
hey, camera guy.
And I stopped.
And he said, come here.
And I got very scared,
but I did.
Because I'm cautious.
And he said, would you
take my picture?
I said, why?
I said, I would love to take
your picture, but why?
He said, well, I've got a
granddaughter, and she I
haven't seen her in several
years, and want
her to know I'm OK.
So I got really honored,
and we took pictures.
And then the next day, I came
back, and I brought my laptop,
and I had all the pictures I
took, because I took it easily
100, and I would have taken
1,000 but he got tired.
And we sent the pictures, and
we edited them together.
We sent them off, and then a few
weeks later, he came and
he had a letter back from her.
And it was magnificent.
And then he gave me this big
stinky hug, with clothes that
hadn't been washed in probably
a year or two.
And we--
one of the most amazing
moments of my life.
Now, I'm telling you
stories now.
I've obviously written these
things down, but it's
important to me.
It's important to me to share
because I want you to know
that things like homelessness
are things that we need to not
allow, we need to raise
our voices on.
But also because as human beings
to human beings, making
those connections, making his
day just by doing something by
talking to him, by noticing him,
is something that's very
important to me.
So here we are in Chinatown
with Richard.
And long story short, I went
in and I bought four Peking
ducks and a couple of racks of
ribs, and we sat and we just
took stuff.
But I saw this--
it looks much better on my
screen, by the way--
and I had to talk to him, and I
had to find out what's going
on, and I had to share it.
And then I started playing
a little bit.
So this is from an ongoing
series called Fallen, because
in my mind, what if these
people roaming among us,
homeless, what if they really
were the angels
put down upon us?
This is Scottie, he's from a
little bit further south, and
I think the post on
this was start by
covering left hand side.
Sorry, I'm a little backwards.
Start by covering that,
and look at that man.
He's got three children, he's
had three companies that he
was CEO of.
Had a big car, had a boat, was
happily married, and then he
started drinking.
Now cover that and
look at this guy.
And now he's lost everything.
And depending on when you see
these people, you're going to
see a different aspect
of them.
I was fortunate in that on
this day, I saw both.
Because I came back
later in the day.
Because that was my morning
shot, and then that was the
afternoon shot.
This is a guy named Russell.
Harriet, who sang me a beautiful
song, and I wish I'd
had my video recorder, because
I wanted to take the lyrics
down, because it was about a
brown eyed guy from New York,
and it just went on and on,
and it was magnificent.
And then that led me to starting
a project with a guy
named Mike Shaw, who is another
kindred spirit of
mine, who lives in the UK, where
we talked about the need
to spend time with people and
connect with people and use
our words with people.
And then that led to a statement
that I've had
written down for years, and
I've made a campaign--
because as a photographer and as
an advertising guy, I have
the ability to put messages
out there, at least in my
social networks, but
also in media--
about don't spare change,
make change.
That led me to veterans.
This is also a guy named
Richard, and
this is what I saw.
He's a World War II vet, and
he's bitter, and as we talked
about things, we got him to
open up and smile, and see
that there were possibilities.
And this is where I left him.
Now, homelessness and veterans
married for me in this world.
This is on Veterans
Day, and this is a
homeless guy named Stefan.
And the fact here is that one in
four veterans are homeless
in this country, are homeless
at some point coming back.
So don't spare change, make
change, and meeting veterans,
it took me to all
sorts of places.
And so the connections that you
make, the people that you
meet the stories of theirs
that you can share.
By the way, every single one of
them, of these people, have
allowed me to tell their
stories, because I do ask.
I think that's critically
important in street
photography for me.
Whenever I'm going to add a
story to an image, I have to
get permission.
Did I get your permission,
Brian?
I know I--
sort of.
OK.
So this led to a whole series of
veterans, and I'm not going
to take you through all
of that just in
the interest of time.
But here's another story that
I want to tell you.
It's Veterans Day.
Not a great shot, but there are
thousands and thousands of
photographers accompanying the
tens of thousands of veterans
in New York.
And someone brought an eagle,
because it's our simple of
patriotism.
And the eagle is sitting
proudly, and he's looking, and
you have the beautiful soldiers
behind, and everyone
was photographing, and it
was a sea of shutters.
I mean, it was like listening to
the ocean over rocks, there
were that many shutters going
constantly, and so the sound,
the sonic branding that was
going on was incredible.
But then the eagle looked down
for a second, and it got
deathly quiet.
Except for me, because I had
to keep clicking, because
there was a moment that I saw.
But it was odd to me, that among
all these photographers,
you would think that everyone
would just keep shooting, but
nobody did.
And so I recall the silence, and
that silence combined with
the image for me, on Veterans
Day, where we're remembering
our fallen, is incredibly
powerful.
But you would never know that if
you saw this image without
the story, without the
words, would you?
Nor would you know how much I
care, how deeply important
this is to me.
So I want you all to think about
that as you're taking
your pictures.
What's important to you?
And are you telling as much
of a story as you want to?
So there's the first thing
to put out there.
This is a guy named
Rocco Moretto.
He's a World War II vet,
three Purple Hearts.
His platoon landed on
Omaha Beach during
the Battle of Normandy.
He was one of two survivors
of his original platoon.
Two.
I met him on Veterans Day, and
I got to meet him and get to
know him, and his girlfriend
Margie, who was a World War II
woman's Army Corps person.
Didn't realize they were
boyfriend and girlfriend til
just a few months ago, but they
were always together.
And so you see these two
90-year-old World War II vets,
and it's a magnificent thing.
And Lockheed Martin called
me a few months ago and
commissioned me to do a series
on veterans as a result of my
passion for this.
And so, that was a big
honor, but then--
and Rocco was one of the first
people I asked to shoot.
And we got to know each
other better.
And then a few days after that,
he called me, and he was
calling me like 40 times a day
leading up to the shoot.
Are we still on, are we still
on, where are we meeting, what
should I bring, what
should I wear?
It was great.
Because if you remember, a
few months ago, I lost my
grandmother.
But I found a grandfather.
A magnificent, heroic, tiny
little grandfather who loves
cannolis, and pasta, and
just listening to
stories about my children.
And he called me, and
he said, the VFW--
Veterans of Foreign Wars Hall
in Queens, that he was a
member of--
was being renamed after
himself, and
would I be his guest?
So I went.
Right?
Right, this--
I know.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Keep going.
[INAUDIBLE].
ALAN SHAPIRO: And so, what you
can't see are the hundreds of
people behind Rocco.
But at some point after the
outside ceremony, where we had
congressman and senators and all
of these people, because
he's a big deal.
There aren't that many World
War II vets left.
This wonderful singer started
singing Andrews Sisters songs
and crooning to him, and
everyone was behind me, and
that's what I saw.
And it was dark, and I didn't
have a flash, and didn't even
want to bring a flash because
that would be disrespectful.
I didn't want to interrupt
what was going on.
And so it's what I think is a
crappy photo, but for me, it
is incredibly iconic, and it
speaks to me just like the
"Life" magazines and "Look"
magazines that I used to look
at it as a kid, and I see
that same thing in it.
And that makes me proud,
because it
means I'm getting somewhere.
That I'm seeing things
differently.
But more importantly is
that I was there to
share it with him.
And that's what I want
you to know about me.
When I meet people like Francis,
the first thing he
told me is he just came out of
a coma six months ago, and he
was immediately taken to jail.
And he just got out.
And he wouldn't tell me why he
was in jail, or why he was in
the coma, but they
were related.
And don't call me Fran, or
Frank, or anything, you have
to call me Francis.
Which immediately, I laughed,
and so he gave me that look.
And I said, oh shit, oh drat.
And that's the photo.
And there was a lot more to it,
and now he invites me to
his mixed martial arts meets,
where he gets to beat up
people who are even meaner
looking than him.
These are his hands,
by the way.
This is a Houston
Street Romeo.
Brian knows Houston Street.
He was cruising uptown chicks.
I just walked over and
I said, I need your
hat, can I have it?
Can I buy it?
And he said, no, because
it is made for my head.
And we had this ongoing
conversation, and you know
that hat, I mean, he spent at
least 20 minutes putting his
hat on at exactly
the right angle.
You knew that, and practicing
his smile at home.
Well, at least I hope you know
from looking at the picture,
but if you didn't know that from
looking at the picture,
now you know it, because
it's written down.
Again, I don't mean to beat a
point into the ground, beat a
dead horse.
This kid had never
heard of Steven
Spielberg or "The Goonies".
So I pulled out my phone, and
I pulled up a YouTube clip,
and I said, oh my god, when they
do the modern day remake,
I'm calling Steve, you're
first in line.
That was the look I got when I
told them that I could call
Steven Spielberg.
The ugliest girl in your grade
has a crush on you.
Go.
Because sometimes when you
find the right people to
connect with, to talk to--
this happens to be my daughter's
friend, Will--
it's amazing the expressions
you get.
You just have to be prepared
to make that connection.
And it doesn't always work.
I mean, you have to be a good
gauge of character in order to
know what you can do with some
people, where you can just
offer up generic questions
and get wonderful
answers, visual answers.
We were talking about tomatoes,
and heirloom
tomatoes in particular, and
salsa recipes in its absolute
particular thing.
And I told him that
I hated salsa.
Mind you, the conversation about
salsa went on for 15
minutes before I finally
dropped that bomb.
It's like, I just don't like
it, I don't get it.
Click.
This woman recently arrived
from the Middle East--
I don't recall the country,
it's somewhere
on one of my writings--
where her husband beat her,
after her father had beaten
her, after her grandfather had
beaten her mother, and so on,
and so forth.
And so she came to this
country to be free.
So sad eyed girl without a
little bit of the back story.
And I could go on with
the backstory.
This gentleman wanted
to be a waiter.
Can you imagine him coming
up and saying,
can I take your order?
I met him on the street, and
that was the look I got, and
it just went on from there.
I think there's another one.
I said, well, OK, so let's see,
I order ketchup with my
foie gras, what's the face
you're going to make?
And we've got to that.
Here's a World War II veteran,
but from the other side.
And his family came
from Hiroshima.
And so we were talking
about that.
And this is a little girl, and
I said, can you imagine if I
went into your room and
tore all the heads
off your teddy bears?
That's the look I got.
And I said, OK, you win.
Because clearly she was going
to rip my head off.
This is the nation's most
famous boylesque dancer.
I think he goes by the
name of Tigger.
I don't know if he still goes
by the name of Tigger.
Doing his best Al Jolson
at the Mermaid
Parade in Coney Island.
And a starving artist.
I'm going to go through.
But what started to happen to
me is, as part of my daily
exercise, I started thinking
about another day.
And that's the genesis of the
"Another Day, Another 600
Seconds" that Mike and I did.
Spend 10 minutes with people.
See the difference it makes.
But here another day, another
10 round fight with the
checkbook, dealing with the
mortgage, car payments, two
college tuitions, and far too
many other assorted monthly
bills that aren't going to pay
themselves while dreaming of
being a Bruce Willis
understudy.
So it becomes a little
bit of a creative
writing exercise, sometimes.
Because I know what's going
on, but I'm looking for
something that will
complement it.
And here, another day, another
few dollars closer to bringing
his family to America, where his
granddaughters can expect
to receive an education,
rather than beatings.
Social commentary.
It can be important, and when
you have a platform like
Google+, why not use it?
Now, I'm not looking to pick
fights, and I'm not looking to
stand on a soapbox, but things
that are important to
me help define me.
And if I can't bring attention
to them, who can?
So maybe we all have obligations
to talk about
stuff that people aren't
talking enough about.
And yeah, people can unblock me,
and uncheck me, and mute
me, and do whatever, but what
is the obligation of a
photographer?
What is the obligation
of a human being?
Rhetorical question, because I
don't really have the answer,
and I don't want to
take it too far.
But that context
and all of that
stuff is really important.
Connections.
Making connections
using your words.
When you have a 14-year-old son,
using your words is an
interesting thing.
But I can tell you that when I
asked Drew if he would pose
for me with an octopus--
that was the first
conversation--
I got the biggest smile
I'd seen ever.
And when I was doing the shoot
with him, and I pulled this
octopus out of milk-- because
that's the only way you can
somewhat get rid
of the smell--
and put it on his head, and
watched him gag and retch.
And I thought, as a father,
this is the most defining
moment ever.
It is perfection
times infinity.
And then he started laughing
and smiling.
And so, for that afternoon
that we were shooting--
because I wouldn't
let them go.
This was not going to be a 10
minute shoot, this was going
to be as long a shoot as
I had memory cards for.
Payback for everything, Drew.
One of the best photographic
experiences of my life.
But as a proud father, and as a
teacher, I want you to think
about those opportunities.
Because I know lots of people
who say, I can't approach
people on the street.
I'm scared of them.
Well then, do something fun with
your kids, or your wife,
or your husband.
So this is my daughter, Lindsay,
because I had to get
her into the picture, too.
This is a little bit later.
I have hissing cockroaches from
Madagascar in my home office.
I don't know why, my daughter
wanted them because she's like
a nature freak, next Jane
Goodall, hi Lindsay.
And then she got tired
of them, so they
ended up with me.
And they really are awesome
creatures, and they're like
this big, and she was jealous
of the octopus
shoot, so we did this.
Because it's like, how do you
top sort of a live, fresh
octopus on your head?
Well let's go with the
hissing cockroaches.
We'll see how tough you are for
your next trip to Borneo.
And I added textures and things
like that, because I
was playing as a creative guy.
Again, another incredible
opportunity.
So for the parents out there
who want to do stuff with
photography, try one
of these exercises.
Think of the grossest thing
you could do to your
kids, and beg them.
And guess what?
You may not have to beg them.
And here's a follow up shot,
because we wanted, again, I
have to stretch it out.
Because it's torture,
it's payback.
It's all those things.
Because we all know, 14-year-old
kids are pure
evil, and when she walks into
the room, she levitates and
all the doors in the
house close, and
it gets really cold.
That's just the way it is.
And then she smiles and
says, hi Daddy,
and it all goes back.
Where was this taken?
Beautiful silverback gorilla.
Rare, rare to have eye contact,
if you're believe the
National Geographic
photographers.
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: Bronx Zoo?
ALAN SHAPIRO: Right.
Bronx Zoo.
But it could've been Uganda.
So does that matter?
Probably not.
But when you start thinking
about images like this, is he
on the outside or the inside?
And maybe, just maybe, for those
photographers who don't
write, maybe adding a little
bit of context will help.
Either tell the story
you want to tell.
Because this obviously--
obviously, in quotes--
is a gelada, cousin to a baboon,
who's inside, who's
trapped, who's sad.
But I can tell you, because I
was there taking this picture,
that this was the happiest
gelada ever, and he was
outside because, I was inside.
And he just was so curious
with the people
coming by with whatever--
his keepers, his handlers, his
photographers like me, who had
the privilege of going
right up there--
that he would come and he would
sit with his feet up,
and he would watch.
And I swear, if I put a can of
popcorn there, he would have
had it in his hand, with the
exact same look and popped it
in his mouth.
He was so happy.
But you'd never know it.
So it's my decision.
Do I share the story or not?
Because I can use it
in one of two ways.
Use your powers for
good or for evil.
You choose.
But if you're not doing
something, if you're not
adding those words, you're
just being irresponsible.
God, that was a strong word.
You're being lazy.
Another strong word.
You're not telling as much of
the story as you could tell,
and it's doing yourself
a disservice.
Here's another question
for the group.
Take the favorite photograph
you've ever taken, and even
for those of you who don't
think of yourselves as
photographers--
just like family historians,
documentarians--
think of the favorite photo that
you ever took, and think
about your great great
grandchildren looking at it
some time in the future.
What are they going to know?
We don't live in an age where we
can scribble on the back of
a photograph, but we do live in
an age where we can catalog
everything on social networks
and personal portfolio sites.
But if you're not doing that
beyond metadata, beyond this
is this point in time and here's
what was going on, et
cetera, et cetera,
lost opportunity.
I just love this image, because
I did a whole long
conversation between the two
gibbons about what it was.
It's not a hippopotamus, even
though it looks like
hippopotamus and it sort of
smells like a pig, and it just
went to this whole, it was like
me writing a comedy bit.
And I probably should've
put it here, because
it really was funny.
Trust me, I'm a good writer.
But whatever.
Same thing with the gelada.
Is this dog happy or sad?
I can tell you this is a world
champions sled dog,
lead sled dog, dog.
Happy as a pig in mud.
Safe, comfortable, in the
freezing cold northern
Canadian wilderness
that I was in.
So happy, and you'd
never know it.
Same thing here.
Without the story, the guy in
the middle had just finished
having his way with his
two favorite ladies.
Does he look sad?
I don't know.
Now that you know what's going
on, is he just tired and
wishing he had a cigarette?
Power of story and context.
I'm going to go a little
quicker here.
Now, education is important,
I said that before.
I started a series a few years
ago for the Ritz Carlton
hotels, textured birds.
I was inspired by the
Renaissance portrait show at
the Metropolitan Museum of
Art, and I just wanted to
recreate it.
And so I started doing these
things, and immediately people
start saying, well, how
do you do that?
Well, the decision is made.
Do you tell them or not?
And of course I'm of
the mindset of
course you show them.
You show them, and show
them, and show them.
And thanks to Hangouts on air,
and all the wonderful things
that you all have provided,
it allows me to teach.
I have my own television
network, I have my own TV
channels, and shows that we all
can do, and all that does
this make me better, and make
me happy when I see people
being inspired by the work.
So share using your words, for
good, to make other people
better I don't know, I'd say
that's a pretty important
thing once you get to a certain
level of maturity.
I was channeling Ansel Adams.
I wanted to be him for
a period of time.
I was in a really dark place,
literally and figuratively,
emotionally.
And it's amazing what happens
when you just go for a walk
when you're in a bad
place, because, in
this case, it follows.
Sometimes happy places find
you, but it allows me to
excise demons, so to speak.
We had Hurricane Sandy last
year on the east coast.
I'm sure some of you may
have heard of it.
But we've also catastrophes,
and I didn't want to go out
and shoot, because it
felt too personal.
Because so many people had lost
things, and this is the
Hudson River.
So I went to a part that I
normally go to shoot sunsets.
We have crappy sunsets
on the east coast.
You guys, I'm so jealous, you
have much better sunsets.
And this is what I saw.
And it took me an hour, normally
a five minute drive,
to get to this place, because so
many trees were down and so
many roads were closed.
And it was really despondent.
It was so sad that this
was going on.
And then I took a walk
further that way, and
this is what I found.
I found this glass is half full,
I'm excited, fishing's
is going to be friggin'
awesome!
And immediately my mood lifted,
and I had to share it.
I had to share it because so
many people on the east coast
were so funked out.
And so being able to talk
about it helps.
This is from a photo walk I
just did in your honor a
couple of weeks back.
My first time over the Brooklyn
Bridge, and there was
this couple, and they seem to
be kind of happy before.
And I called her over, and I
said, how do you really feel.
Is this the guy you're
going to marry?
I said hold that thought.
Go back.
I called him over.
How do you feel about
this girl?
You're going to show
me in a second.
Hold the thought.
And I said OK, show me how you
feel about each other.
Click.
So it's fun to talk to people.
It's fun.
Including people you would
never ever talk to.
Because this guy was
kind of scary, too.
Anyone who had tattooed their
face, I mean, they would think
nothing like taking a spork
and trying to tattoo mine.
That's kind of the thing.
So it's also a little bit of
confidence builder, a bit of a
creative exercise to go and
approach someone and to say,
oh my god, you are fascinating,
and I just want
to take your picture.
May I please?
Not yours, yours.
And sometimes it's like
making that decision.
Because when you get a group of
interesting people, I want
you, but then this one wants
to get into the equation.
All right, now go ahead.
Or you get a group mentality and
you start playing one off
the other, like all right, show
me something, good, OK,
now your turn, now your
turn, your turn.
You lose, you're out.
Now, with three of you,
let's do it again.
Now give me a little bit more.
So that's the fun of being
a photographer.
But it's also the fun of telling
these stories, now in
words, but in spoken word rather
than written word.
I have a thing for
tattoos, I guess.
Sometimes themes start
to emerge for me.
I talked about teachers
before.
This woman is a teacher
from Selma, Alabama.
So I think back to my history,
and she was of a certain age,
and we started an entire
conversation about
segregation, and about Doctor
King, and about things that
were important to me and clearly
life changing for her.
And I asked her to think about
those moments and close your
eyes, and think back.
And in this case, normally I
would wait for them to open
their eyes, but I saw something
in her eyes closed,
because of the earlier
conversation that I just had
to capture.
This wasn't a mistake.
This was keep your eyes
closed please.
And that led to this idea of
seeing what people look like
with their eyes closed.
This woman wouldn't close
her eyes from me.
Same place though.
All of these people are from
the deep South and lived
through segregation.
And I just find it interesting
when we talk about it and we
put things together.
And the last one.
And sometimes images are
powerful together, but if I
hadn't told you that this was
people thinking about
segregation, my guess is it
wouldn't have been as
important to you.
And here's parade shot
one, parade shot two.
Same parade.
Veterans Day.
Father's on the float,
father is overseas.
Teachers really important
to me.
Pay teachers like rock stars.
These are both teachers, and
when I was talking about just
that, you guys should make a
million dollars, $10 million,
you should have concerts
sold, filled if
you're a good teacher.
We should fill arenas
so that you can
broadcast your message.
That's what I believe.
And that was his reaction.
And that was her reaction.
Processed differently,
but that's the fun.
And lastly this is
show me love.
Actually, show me hate,
Hate, love.
One of my fun things to do.
And we're going to end with
a little pretty couple of
things, because I meet a lot of
people, and I hear a lot of
stories that make me feel
a range of things.
They make me feel happy in a lot
of cases, but they make me
feel despair, and anger, and
want to do something.
And it can get to me, because
I'm an emotional guy, and so I
used to say, when things are
looking down find something
beautiful looking up.
There's a one liner, there's
a cliche to put on the wall
somewhere, or a Hallmark card.
And so I started shooting
flowers to make me happy.
To write love notes with.
To do whatever I need to do.
But there's always a story
that goes with
the flowers, as well.
And that's the talk.
When are you use your words,
your world will expand.
Here's two lines to end--
photography can make you think,
and make you feel.
Photographs and words
can make you do.
Thank you.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: How do you best share
your stories with photos
using online media?
Because I have I Plus and
Facebook and Smugmug, and lots
of platforms, but haven't really
settled on one or kind
of figured out what the best way
to have that archive and
share it effectively.
So I'd love to hear what--
ALAN SHAPIRO: I have embraced
Google+ huge, having been a
Facebook person for as long
as they were around.
Really, as a marketing person,
it's important to me to
understand social media.
It's the game changer, in recent
times, for brands and
marketers, so it's important.
So when Google+ first
came out, OK, join.
See what it's like.
And hope that the experience
would deliver what it did.
That a true community
would be formed.
But to answer your question, I
have a blog that I wonder if I
even need, because of
my Google+ presence.
When I remember, I
post to Facebook.
When I remember, because it's
out of sight, out of mind,
thankfully.
I do have a portfolio site, and
I do maintain presences on
things like [INAUDIBLE], because
of the connection to
Adobe, and even prior to them.
But what I would say to you is
where are the people you want
to talk to you?
And if you know where they are,
you'll very quickly be
able to figure out how to reach
them very selectively.
And until someone makes a
plug-in-- because we've tried,
in the advertising world.
There have been many dashboards
created where you
can take an image and you can
post it to all of the various
social networks, and
Twitter, et cetera.
But everyone's different,
and it still becomes
kind of time consuming.
So where do you want
to be heard?
I can get specific off camera,
I just you know, don't.
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: Regarding your comment
about talking about
your pieces, I tend not to talk
about my photos because I
don't want to limit the response
of the viewer.
Do you ever consider that?
Is that a concern for you?
ALAN SHAPIRO: It used to be.
But it was a conscious decision
for me to want to
tell a bigger story than
the photo would.
Having talked to a bunch of my
friends in the online world--
is it a good thing,
is it a bad thing?
That's the question I posed.
Many of them had this told me
that sometimes they'll read my
comments first, and sometimes
they'll wait for later,
depending on what I'm posting.
If it's a particularly
provocative image to them,
they'll look at the image, and
they'll take it in, and
they'll form their opinion,
and then they'll go and
they'll look at the comment.
And I think audiences are smart
enough these days to be
able to discern.
But if you don't post it,
something else is
going to come up.
Life is going to pick you up
and plop you down somewhere
else, and you'll forget, and
then that may be the moment
that your great grandchildren
choose to look at and wonder
what was going on.
So I always do it.
AUDIENCE: So obviously, attached
to each picture, you
have very fond memories, and
you're very capable of, it
seems like, connecting
via empathy with the
photos that you take.
Which is really admiring.
But then, how much time do you
spent translating that into a
story, that then you associate
with your picture, and how do
you keep track of the
story plus the
picture together in this--
I'm sure you take thousands
of photos.
ALAN SHAPIRO: Yeah, as a
creative thinker, right?
I mean, that's my job.
My job is to make order out of
chaos, is to solve problems
creatively.
Sometimes I'll look at an
image and I'll know
immediately what I want
to say, and it
will flow like water.
And sometimes I will look at an
image and nothing will come
other than the absolute obvious,
but it's a particular
image that I don't want to be
obvious with, and so I'll
spend a little bit more time
thinking about. it.
So I consider it, like any
creative exercise any one of
us has ever gone through,
sometimes it's easy,
sometimes it's not.
AUDIENCE: So, in addition to
that, tactically, how do you
associate this?
What do you do to keep photo
one is story one.
Do you know what I mean?
Because you can't just--
ALAN SHAPIRO: I don't sleep
much, and so normally, when I
come back, and I'll edit, I'll
do a very quick edit, and I've
also got a pretty
decent memory.
I'm not sure it's photographic,
but it's pretty
damn close.
So I just remember--
other than how to spell--
I remember names and
things like that.
And it's important to me.
So when it's important to you,
you tend to remember more.
So it just--
it happens.
Does that help you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ALAN SHAPIRO: I used to use a
manual typewriter when I was a
little kid, and I think
something about that
experience relates now to
why I love photography.
The shutter, the pressing of
a button, different from a
keyboard, different from
electric typewriter.
So that was random,
but just to share.
AUDIENCE: How do you ice break
with the crowd that you're
walking up to?
Do you have a set of scripts
in your head that you run
through and decide, OK, with
this crowd I want to do this?
Or do you not?
ALAN SHAPIRO: I'm a pretty
good improviser.
There are some situations, I
mean like when you walk into a
room wanting to meet people, and
sort of just being open.
Another one liner that I should
have put in here, the
bigger the smile you give, the
bigger the smile you get.
Right?
So when your friendly, when
you're approachable,
especially when you're
walking around with a
somewhat big lens--
which I like, because it gets
a certain reaction--
I need to--
right?
Its theater.
But I need to balance that
with a little bit of
lightheartedness.
And so sometimes, it's
love your shoes,
tell me about them.
In most cases, unless I'm just
out and about, and I don't
really care, but when I'm on a
mission, I will not even have
my camera up.
I will leave it on my side
while I'm engaging.
And in some cases 10, 15 minutes
can go by just making
conversation with people before
it's like, would you
mind if I took your picture?
And then that gives you the sort
of inspiration to take
them places, tell me more
about fill in the blank.
And sometimes it's as simple
as scream for me.
AUDIENCE: So Thomas Hawk, who
came and talked last year, was
talking about the fact that
when he goes out into San
Fransisco, to the pan handlers
and takes their pictures, he
actually offers them $1 to take
their pictures, because
that way, he gets a great
picture, and they get $1.
I don't know if you've done
anything like that.
ALAN SHAPIRO: I respect
Thomas, I do that.
I buy them lunch, I buy them
dinner, I take them to get
their medicine.
You do what you think
you need to do.
And they're the people
who need it.
So it's the right thing to do.
It shouldn't ever be about
stealing a photo.
In my world, in my style.
I mean, there were street
shooters who certainly believe
in that random, spontaneous
moment, and you can't go up
and approach someone, and
then expect them to
be spontaneous after.
So there's different schools.
For me, it's about engagement,
it's about connecting.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
ideas on how to sort of
include a story with
a physical print?
ALAN SHAPIRO: I would love it
if someone could help me--
and I need to spend more time
talking to the labs.
I need to make time
to do that.
I would love it if, depending
on the type of story teller
you are, you could just mount a
picture of a particular size
with a large enough mat where
you can include it.
And it becomes a design
exercise, if
you think about it.
You're just making an
oversized poster on
photographic paper, watercolor
paper, whatever.
Maybe that's something we should
talk to the Adobe folks
about, or Bay Photo
or whoever.
For me, it's about books.
It's about a longer
form narrative.
As I start looking at the work
I like, and the type of
processing I do-- so a lot of
the on black work I do is from
a series called "Emerging From
Shadows", and so that will go
into a book.
And so it's easy to tell
the stories there.
And a veteran's book, and a
homeless person book, and
whatever happens to come.
But there's no solution.
So if someone comes up with
it, I'd be very grateful.
AUDIENCE: So I'm a photographer,
and I'm one of
the people who struggles to use
my own words, and some of
that is just finding the right
way to tell the story that's
interesting.
And some of it is that I feel
like and emotionally giving
more of myself away than
maybe I'm willing to.
But as a consumer of
photography, are you more
likely to bypass images that
don't have words with them?
ALAN SHAPIRO: Me personally?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ALAN SHAPIRO: No.
No, I'm a lover photography.
I love photographers,
I love the range.
What I find is that there's
a lot of sameness,
though, in our world.
And if I have 20 landscape
photographs in front of me,
they're all beautiful.
The tie breaker, for me, in
terms of making a deeper
connection with the artist,
is how the words enter in.
Because now it becomes
branding.
As a photographer, you want
people to know to you, and how
you feel about a
certain thing.
Put 20 people in front of a
beautiful sunset, and you
might get 20 different photos,
but more likely you'll get 20
photos that are fairly
similar.
So how do you break the tie?
Who do you like more?
And that's where hearing your
point of view, whether it's
the poetry you write, or--
because it doesn't have to
be about personal giving.
I like that for me, but for you,
it may be just helping
educate people, or just
talking about
the sounds you heard.
It doesn't have to take you to a
place that is too revealing.
But it's really about
sharing in this
wonderful world of ours.
It's what I want to do.
AUDIENCE: I know you, and still,
listening to you talk
and seeing the images.
I do photography and voice over,
and I taught voice for
25 years, and I know voice
intimately, and things about
the voice and the sound, and the
reason I ask the question
about do you ever record, first,
I thought their voice,
just because the thing about
a voice is it carries the
complete imprint of who you
are, on every level.
So the photographs are just
unbelievable, and the stories
are even more so.
And then I think about the
recordings of my mother that
her family made when
she was maybe 15.
She and her father
sang together.
And I know, obviously, right
now, you've only been shooting
for a few years, and this is all
very new, but of course,
as we know, we think a little
further than today.
I don't know.
It's just an interesting
thought.
And then hearing you, and the
passion and the heart and soul
in your voice about the whole
thing is just so powerful.
ALAN SHAPIRO: Thank
you for that.
I think, for me, there's still
a barrier between--
as ubiquitous as photography
has become.
Everyone's a photographer.
Unless you don't have a mobile
device with a camera built in,
you're a photographer.
So everyone is used to
having pictures be
taken, but they're still--
if I hold something up,
something happens, right?
The synapses in your brain
say fight or flight?
Smile?
What do I do?
Fear?
It happens.
Add a microphone on top of that,
or anything where now
you're asking them to behave
even more, and for me, it
seems like that's another
plateau that I
would love to get to.
Not yet.
There's still too many
people to me.
Yeah, well, I'll do
that on a show.
AUDIENCE: Some of the recent
G+ UI changes seem to
accentuate the visual
over the text.
ALAN SHAPIRO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Tell us how
you feel about that.
ALAN SHAPIRO: I think you need
to give people choices.
And you clearly do.
And so whether I love a bigger
picture, a smaller picture, a
sharper picture, or not, as long
as I have the ability--
because I've got a caption box,
and I've got the ability
to post, and so I've got two
places to leave different
messages, and sometimes they're
the same, because it's
not easy to go from one
to the other for me.
But as long as I'm able to
tell my story in your
technology, I will embrace it.
The photography community's
really vibrant on Google+.
Incredibly vibrant, which is one
of the reasons some there.
But if you're a writer who wants
to add visuals, right?
If you're the opposite person to
me, my paramour over here,
how would they feel?
And so, as long as you're
dealing with your audience the
way you want them to embrace
you, then that's fine.
But give me the ability to
change fonts, because
sometimes I want to yell and
sometimes I don't, and that
would make it ugly, and so we
can't do that, and so it
doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter as long
as I can tell the
story, perfect for me.
Pleasure, thank you.